hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to troll face quest 5 the
last game in the troll face quest series
as far as I know because no other game
has been made yet but that doesn't mean
that we're not gonna have fun because
this one is about the Olympics and oh no
it's not about the Olympics it's about
the World Cup which is like the Olympics
for football non americano if you're not
from America and you needyou that
explain anyway so what happens is you're
in the stands you're cheering on for the
troll Cup for everyone who wants to win
that because no one really wants to win
that anyway but it's this guy versus
that guy and you know how these games go
I mean it's gonna make me feel like an
idiot over and over again oh that was
bro okay yeah that was probably the
obvious answer that wasn't gonna let me
win what about this one the shaking
dancing troll wow I just got kicked in
the balls that's hilarious that's the
source of all comedy put a football in
my new it's okay so what do I do with
that oh my god chop his head off like
Edward scissor oh oh
red card I know that way why why is he
saluting oh that doesn't make any sense
at all cuz in soccer or football de
marrón non americano it's it's okay I
don't even understand that at all but
hey I gave him a red card and I tossed
him out of the field but he saluted it
as if he was saluting a flag or
something
moon done whoo there's a number of
clicks that I'm clicking okay yeah that
made sense that accomplished my goal
winning the World Cup for the Romanov
futbol americano my country that's not
the United States and so sad I blew up
the world maybe I don't need to pump it
up that much that good enough ray I'm
logical and smart well not really my
markiplier that's not exactly what I do
at all why are you cold you need a shirt
I'm sure these are soccer references
that I should know
okay so and I'm gonna have to take off
your clothes first and I'm obviously not
gonna win any high scores on this
clicking meter because that's not a
thing that I'm doing I'm not in this to
win this I'm in this to lose this and
make me feel as bad as possible like the
Americans when they play soccer
haha I don't know if that's true well
it's probably funny hahahaha can you
give okay wait oh good
wait wait stop being cold and for some
reason that makes him feel better
because he has less clothes on I know
he's dead so just a little bit and then
we look on the trollolol on ik while
you're drinking the trololo tonic and
then like sonic we got to go troll a
little fast on ik Oh what is this Oh
superpower mix that without goal I'm
sure that'll go well that's what they
call in soccer or net football not
americano they called the gaming field
what do I got there I don't even want to
know what's in here huh I knew the
secret and you're saluting me again for
some are you listening in your ear
cuz you're a Secret Service guy bang on
that drum bang your own drum while
watching football non americano that's
what I wanted to do I don't understand
this at all oh the Lulu failure vuvuzela
damn it
play your vuvuzela how do you play your
vuvuzela haha oh oh I see well you can't
really
[Music]
hey man I didn't get off on my knees get
home now yo now it's kind of a loser oh
do I need to put one up my behind - no
that could have been a good fart
vuvuzela but I didn't - enough yes
inject me with that I want that right in
me me me Amy oh I turned into the Hulk
and then I died how about whatever this
is behind there oh I see
well now I'm I'm even okay because
that's all that matters being
symmetrical hey wait you're weird you're
a troll man that feel good so feel good
you're gonna impress all the people on
the field today the gaming field
[Music]
something doesn't seem fair about this
has allowed me to succeed in life isn't
that the American dream okay no I don't
want it I don't want to click there no
it's a trap it's a damn trap I tell ya
it's rolling down a trap but it's really
trapping my body
ah see it was a trap kind of want to
find out what the trap was though Wow
giraffe Oh banana that was not a giraffe
okay what we've got here
this guy looks Shady's Frick boom how do
you like a dead rat huh lady day right
one dead rat little kid
nutritious delicious it's good for you
may not be good for you you'd probably
enjoy this how about you your big nose
you liked it right there yes like that
you'd like that tickly in the tendrils
of your nostrils you like it
would you grandma I seemed awfully
malicious now that was scary
now do I do all right cool is just great
I'm glad to do it okay I win now yeah
I'm up in the air oh no that's bad I
should probably okay alright I don't
know why I'm in a blimp by the wha what
if I don't do anything was this the
solution with me the whole time but even
when I was falling why didn't I just put
that on and go on with my life this is a
silly game this game is silly
that's hasn't make any sense at all
you're being silly nothing I know
anything about sports but I know that's
wrong my stance okay it's can they even
have a football team or a football non
americano doesn't belong face is ugly
and you should eat your sweater but
they're not really soccer balls are they
their hats earthy their hats they're
just hats you freak your hats your
stupid little child their hats
your dreams are [ __ ] Oh No
well okay they've mission accomplished
we crushed two child's dreams
how dare he think for himself yeah yeah
our our side of the world is marginally
better than your side of the world
therefore you should shove off whatever
side bye
okay it's some combination this Oh
hey not bad I still think they're
fighting and beating each other up but
at least it looks better now okay so
it's come to this the final showdown
let's see what you got oh that's what I
wanted to do am i playing is the troll
or am i playing is the dude now I don't
really know oh yeah
food bomb not americano troll Cup oh oh
I know what I need to do I know that
laughs mater means I know what it means
[Music]
[Laughter]
okay that's amazing I just spit
everywhere oh we did it just over five
hundred clicks later wait did it where
we should be so proud of ourselves on
our football non americano team good job
everybody couldn't have done it without
you or whatever I don't really know
anymore understand anything my life is a
lie I thought I was on level 90 but a
bird oh that's right I was on level 20
well that's all for trollface quest 25
just 5 not 20 so so anyway I guess I'm
done with this series for now I had a
blast playing these games I really did
have a lot of fun just because it made
me feel like an idiot over and over
again hey I got to be silly and play a
silly game and sometimes that's just the
best thing gamers can enjoy I'm back
from New York now so I'm back into the
swing of recording things so thank you
everybody so much for watching and as
always I will see you in the next video
flu from the hair hair food
just losing my hair
I'm gone trust me not here anymore
I should probably shut up now breaks the
illusion but I'm gone gone
oh I forgot I'm not captain falcon